is it hard like because I have cousins
that have been like in and out of prison
their whole lives and I feel like you
get out of jail
you get out of prison rather whatever it
is and it's almost like
hard to shake like is it the environment
is it the friend group is it the
mentality what do you think it is that
like most people go through when it
comes to like ending up back in the same
place not even yourself specifically I
mean you obviously know a lot of people
who have
um well you just gotta change yo your
direction like you got to change your
direction to people you're around or the
things that you're doing like because
I could still be around the same [ __ ]
who's out here committing crimes and
[ __ ] but I'm not necessarily going to
put myself in a position to where I'ma
be going back to jail you feel like I
only go to jail for guns right every
time I go to jail it's for guns so for
me not to go back to jail I can't
surround myself in certain areas where
I'ma need a gun and if I do then you
feel also like you gotta be just mindful
of the environment we're in now man our
[ __ ] is getting killed and
nothing and that's the thing for us
Rolex for it's crazy like you know Rolex
we just talk about pnb rock like yeah
that was crazy insane man like dudes at
at a restaurant eating with this girl
and in front of [ __ ] is bold now
because back in my day we was robbing
[ __ ] a week our main thing was [ __ ]
don't
because that's when your charges get
serious don't shoot nobody that was like
we didn't want to shoot nobody never
wanted to shoot nobody if you robbing
them now you getting shot before you
getting robbed you getting shot then
robbed yeah or the other way you're
getting robbed and still getting shot
man that's [ __ ] up these [ __ ] crazy
yeah cause like you said like if the
goal is not to shoot anybody because
that's when you you're gonna go to
prison for life people are still robbing
you and then just shooting you just
that's because that's cause look at the
world now though everybody got ski mask
huh everyone's got the [ __ ] sheisty
it's legal to write or be anywhere in
any business organization with a ski
mask so when you seeing this [ __ ] every
day a [ __ ] walk through with a ski mask
on you just look at him whatever now
[ __ ] walking in with ski masking this
[ __ ] fitting to do something somebody
you don't even know because you see this
every day you see somebody walking with
a ski mask on every day so you're kind
of comfortable with it now because you
you see it so much yeah so this is
getting bold because [ __ ] you can't see
nobody face